now that there's a food theory channel
do you go over here on film theory or
over there on food theory since you're a
rat who cooks
food theory that sounds like a great
channel i better check it out at the end
of the episode
oh yeah it is an awesome channel where
everyone will immediately want to hit
that subscribe button and ring the
notification
bell but um we're not gonna be friends
at the end of this episode remy wait
what i'm a lovable cartoon rat in a
kid's movie what could i have done wrong
oh man you're talking to a guy who's
ruined some of the most beloved disney
characters of all time the lions from
lion king
strong female characters like rapunzel
like every character from zootopia
wait i know those guys remy you don't
stand a chance
hello internet welcome to film theory
where today's episode is with apologies
to schaeferless productions because uh
no joke this is a pickup line as we were
working on this episode
i'm like oh no it talks about
ratatouille all of a sudden he uploads
this hour-long dissertation on why
ratatouille is this like
masterpiece of filmmaking and how it
touches him emotionally
and yeah today i am here to rip its main
character to shreds
so apologies to you now i can already
hear you moaning in the comments you
think grumpy old matpat's here to ruin
an animated family film from your
childhood as usual but never fear
internet because i'm here to say that
ratatouille is everything a great
g-rated movie should be
it's a fantastic story it has an
uplifting message it has a detestable
bad guy and an admirable protagonist and
in the case of ratatouille
that protagonist is chef skinner the guy
that everyone seems to think is the
antagonist is actually the good guy
what is a typical game theory or film
theory episode i don't know why everyone
thinks
remy the rat who's obviously a dangerous
narcissist
is the good guy but it's high time that
the misconceptions about this rat tale
went the way of the rat tale if it's
been a while since you watched
ratatouille here's a quick refresher
ratatouille stars remy a rat that the
internet will literally barbecue me over
if i accidentally call him ratatouille
it's the name of the movie not the name
of the rat he has a passion for culinary
arts but no reality cooking competition
show to prove it on
he leaves the colony to live his dreams
in the one place that he's not allowed a
gourmet kitchen linguine a young member
of the kitchen staff lets remy hide
underneath his hat this allows remy to
pull on strands of linguine's hair and
control the young man's every move with
remy at the helm linguini impresses
even paris's most formidable food
critics with his inventive cuisine
skinner the highly trained chef at the
restaurant suspects that
something is up and does his best to
uncover the truth about linguine's
newfound talents in the kitchen now if
this sounds like an inspirational story
about overcoming obstacles and achieving
your destiny i'm sorry to tell you that
you've missed the point
entirely the theoretical truth is that
remy is nobody's master chef he's
actually a bold-faced criminal and yeah
i know you're not gonna believe me here
matpat's taking it too far this theory
is gonna be too big of a stretch
i've heard it all and yet for all of my
admittedly outlandish theories hello
finding nemo episode
this one is shockingly down to earth
just listen remy is
an actual dictionary definition criminal
he's kind of a narcissist and he's just
overall a jerk of a creature and if you
look at his on-screen behavior
you'll realize that he's not actually
the good guy here
i smell a rat in this disney classic and
it's
it's remy the rats you get it the first
thing remy did that put a bad taste in
my mouth was establish himself as a
habitual thief now that alone wouldn't
be too big of a problem the real issue
is that he
lies about it he explicitly states that
he's
against stealing a cook makes the thief
takes you are not the thief and yet we
witness remy steal literally the entire
time
herbs spices cookbooks letters and of
course
food remy never learns his lesson either
look it's delicious
but don't steal i'll buy some spices
okay
[Music]
in fact the longer the film goes on the
more brazen he becomes
first he only steals food for himself
but eventually he starts letting his rat
buddies into the restaurant to steal
food after hours you are stealing
you told linguine he could trust me and
he can but zaboy could lose his job
which means i would too it's under
control okay
he's not just stealing on small scale he
is stealing in massive
quantities towards the end of the movie
he lets the entire rat colony have at it
in any realistic context this is
absolutely disgusting
not to mention that restaurants operate
on razor thin margins for their product
so stealing the food here might
literally put them out of business
either for hygiene concerns or at the
very least for them having to throw away
literally tons of food that have been
touched on and nibbled on by a parade of
rats but okay petty thieving
still not enough to turn you against him
how about a nice healthy serving of
fraud
look at linguini poor linguine the
garbage boy
the sap that remy literally controls
like a puppet throughout the movie when
the two of them meet linguini is
destitute
i need this job i've lost so many
i don't know how to cook and now i'm
actually talking to a rat as if you
huh so linguine doesn't know how to cook
lucky for us remy has a great mantra
that he preaches throughout the entirety
of this movie anyone can cook
what do i always say anyone can cook
anyone can cook
so obviously with remy's great skill he
can teach
linguine to cook right uh no
he's nobody who takes out the garbage he
doesn't cook anyone can cook well
yeah anyone can that doesn't mean that
anyone should
instead remy devises a complex system of
hair pulling that allows him to hide
underneath linguine's chef hat and
operate linguine's body as though he
were nothing more than a human forklift
and in the process teach linguine no
useful culinary skills whatsoever and
what's it all for
just so remy can cook just for his own
benefit so rather than teaching someone
a lifelong skill that could
put a roof over their head and make sure
that they keep their job without fear of
being kicked out of the restaurant
because they're keeping an unhygienic
rat under their hat the entire time
he just uses the garbage boy to get
ahead cool cool so okay remy's selfish
he's a hypocrite he's a thief
those are just facts of the movie
they're on screen
they are in the script we get it but
that doesn't mean that he's the
antagonist
necessarily right like after all all
great heroes have their flaws i mean who
hasn't forced
two unconsenting adults to kiss once or
twice am i right
oh no
oh remy that one's gonna get you
canceled on twitter my dude but okay
it's not as though remy's selfishness
puts
others lives at risk or anything right
hey remy you think that maybe we
shouldn't be so
oh oh my he he really is just the
absolute worst disney it's almost like i
told you that in the thesis of this
episode
sorry to break it to you folks but remy
just doesn't give one rat dropping if
anyone around him lives or dies his
singular purpose is to be a chef and he
is going to achieve it no matter how
many
innocent rats or humans are left in his
wake
and spoiler alert both are left dead in
his way
i've already subtly hinted at the fact
that he's you know a rat and rats are
banned from parisian kitchens for a very
good reason
according to the cdc rats and mice are
known to spread over 35 different
diseases to humans worldwide many of
which can be fatal
and remy knows this he understands this
concept
remy without exaggeration kidnaps anyone
who threatens to report the hundreds of
sewer rats running around in the kitchen
oh sure they clean and sanitize
themselves for that final scene
after they've already walked across all
the floors and surfaces but what about
when all of them raid the refrigerator i
don't see any sanitation
happening before or after that scene
what about when they first
invade the kitchen where are the hair
nets people and if you don't think human
health codes are important i encourage
you to read upton sinclair's the jungle
friends spoiler alert rats play a
leading role in that one too
after the jungle was published in 1906
it helped raise public awareness about
the meat packing industry's unsanitary
practices
leading to a massive decrease in typhoid
fever trichinosis and various other
potentially lethal diseases
stop that health inspector no don't remy
that's the point and you know what's
worse than all the crimes that he's
committed to the human world beyond all
the poor workplace conditions
the lying the stealing the unconsenting
kisses
remy's worst offense actually happens
before he even steps foot in the kitchen
at the beginning of the movie remy's
remarkable nose lands him the most
important job in his colony
rat poison sniffer as the only rat in
the entire colony capable of sniffing
out rat poison
remy is able to ensure the colony's food
supply is safe to eat
it's an admirable job where remy
undoubtedly saves lives but he
ultimately abdicates his position in
favor of becoming a chef now
that wouldn't be a problem except for
one thing he is the only rat in the
entire colony with the ability to save
his friends
family and species from a painful
poisonous death and yet you just gotta
go master that beef bourguignon
don't get me wrong here i am all for
pursuing your dream my grandmother still
asks me when i'm gonna get a real job
and move back to ohio but remy's pursuit
of cooking
is literally killing his friends and
family but he's an artist
he needs to spread his wings and fly
sure remy you can play with that nicoise
salad
all you want after you train someone
else to do your life-saving
job nothing's been poisoned thank god
but it hasn't been easy
tldr here is remy doesn't care about
anyone
else he only cares about himself he
doesn't care about saving their lives he
doesn't care about keeping their jobs he
doesn't care about their personal
physical boundaries and he doesn't care
about them keeping healthy off of the
food that they eat
long story short remy is just the worst
but does that mean that this movie is
left with no protagonist in a shocking
twist
no let's shift gears a moment to
consider skinner widely considered to be
the villain of ratatouille even though
we just established that remy fills that
role very nicely it is true that skinner
is diametrically opposed to remy
throughout the story but if remy is
selfish heartless and criminally
dangerous
well what does that say about skinner
exactly because no matter how you slice
it and dice it chef skinner
does nothing wrong if skinner is guilty
of anything it's of presenting as a
villain
the sunken eyes the fits of rage the
pencil thin mustache
dude's not exactly going to be gracing
the cover of a romance novella any time
soon but what is it we're told about
books and covers again
it's a person's actions that truly
matter and if we dive into skinner's
actions we
quickly realize that everything the man
does is above board he is a trained
capable chef who does know good food
when he tastes it chef skinner's game
recognizes game even when it appears as
though the food was made by someone
who's completely untrained he listens to
his staff and he can even admit when
he's wrong
perhaps i have been a bit ash on our new
garbage boy
he has taken a bold risk and we should
reward that
skinner even goes so far to give
linguine an utterly untrained garbage
boy who hasn't worked in a kitchen for
one full shift
more than a fair shot at proving himself
as a real chef
recreate the soup take as much time as
you need
so what then is skinner's crime having a
dislikable demeanor gee can't think of
any other revered
international chef who fits that profile
have you got enough in there
but that's so good it's really a waste
wow and what's more
skinner makes good business decisions
having inherited a restaurant roiling
from the death of gusto
skinner shrewdly pivots the brand and
diversifies the business into a frozen
meal marketplace and frozen meal
business is good
sure it's not as classy or artsy as
being a chef in a fancy french
restaurant but guess what by expanding
into frozen food it ensures that good
quality products are reaching a wider
marketplace who might not be able to
afford eating at gusto's fancy french
revered restaurants
and it sells burritos millions and
millions of burritos that's not a bad
thing that's delivering more food to
more people and making sure that your
business stays profitable moving forward
after losing its headline chef i mean
that is a thankless position and yet
skinner manages to thread that needle
perfectly skinner is also a staunch
defender of the health
code which in 2020 we can certainly see
saves lives
remy isn't exactly washing his hands for
the cdc recommended 40 seconds out there
sure skinner wants remy out of the
kitchen not because he seeks to deny
remy's destiny as an
artist but it's for the pragmatic reason
that his restaurant would be closed down
should the health inspector discover a
rat his staff would be left
unemployed every person in his
restaurant would be at risk of
contracting any of the 35 diseases a
sewer rat like remy could carry
not only is skinner by the book when it
comes to health code violations he is
also
a hundred percent right about remy even
if remy's half-hearted hand-washing were
to somehow rinse all the bacteria from
his body he's still a threat to spread
any of dozens of diseases when he's you
know
biting people all the time
this is not gonna work little chef no
amount of hand washing and external
sanitation is gonna clean the bacteria
out of your mouth and teeth there remy
throughout the film chef skinner is an
absolute boy scout and what does it get
him in the end
kidnapped and hog tied by a horde of
rats and locked in a walk-in
refrigerator alongside a health
inspector by the quote-unquote
good guys but even in the face of this
mafia-esque intimidation
skinner and the health inspector
fearlessly pursue justice once they're
released and ultimately succeed in
getting gustoes closed for health code
violations
skinner had every opportunity to stoop
to remy's level poisoning
lying cheating destroying the evidence
that linguini was actually the rightful
heir and owner of the restaurant but he
doesn't do
any of that he follows the letter of the
law every step of the way
even when it makes him angry or upset in
truth if skinner was truly the
antagonist he could have won
this movie he could have sat back and
sold millions and millions of frozen
burritos well into his golden years but
instead
skinner sacrificed his own career for
the all-important cause of public safety
if the bad rap that skinner got at the
end of this movie doesn't put a bad
taste in your mouth
i don't know what will but hey that's
just a theory
a film theory and a huge
huge thank you to our sponsor for
today's episode epic games and their
massive video game hit of fortnite yeah
we have a gaming channel but they wanted
to sponsor us over here
on film theory which might seem weird
but actually isn't that big of a
surprise considering that they too are
currently crossing genres with their big
season 4 launch the nexus war which
features the ability for you to hop into
the shoes of some of marvel's biggest
heroes and villains including doctor
doom
wolverine iron man man i love that guy 3
000. but uh
perhaps my favorite appearance of the
bunch thor also joining the fortnite
phrase so watch out noob master 69
thor is indeed coming for you he's also
coming for galactus apparently who's
also arriving on the scene i suppose as
the big bad of the season i'm not 100
sure actually i'm excited to find out if
you haven't checked out fortnite yet it
is
unlike anything else out there and the
constant flow of new content that the
epic games team is constantly infusing
the game with is just
really impressive and this new season
comes with some of the coolest additions
yet not only are you getting a bunch of
new characters from the marvel universe
but also their locations on the map like
the sentinel graveyard from x-men
or dr doom's domain plus plus the
characters aren't just running around
with shoddies all the time they're
actually arriving with their powers
groots bramble shield silver surfers
surfboard just really
cool really awesome new details let me
just say it right now i am not what you
would call
good at fortnight but it's times like
this where i'm really happy that i have
an account where i can just dip in and
play some matches and explore the new
characters the new locations the new
powers whatever direction their story is
headed to and at the very least it'll
probably get itself its own film theory
one day since it's now the crossroads of
video games
marvel and star wars meaning that pretty
much everything is canon to everything
else thanks to fortnite
the long and short of it all is this
fortnite is free it's an enormously
robust game that's constantly updating
with really cool new stuff and if you
value
being pop culture literate in even the
slightest way then you owe it to
yourself to play a few matches to just
see what the hype is all about
season four's nexus war is a great time
to jump in it's applicable to gamers
it's applicable to film fans and it's
applicable to you since you know you
watched a video about ratatouille and
last until the end which implies that
you're a fan of disney stuff and since
marvel is now disney you know how it
goes if you haven't downloaded fortnite
already use my link in the description
below and download fortnight now for
free keep an eye out there for me on the
battlefield i'll uh
be the groot standing in the corner
pretending to be a tree before you go if
you do
like theories and food and the big
screen don't forget to check out the
next
course on the theorist menu food theory
it launched a few weeks ago and you guys
have given us tremendously positive
feedback about it over a million of you
subscribed in the first week
alone and the audience for every episode
has been only growing since
if you're into the crossover between
food and movies check out our theory on
how kool-aid man fits into the marvel
universe and is probably a descendant of
x-men
yes really it's a real thing if you're
more of a small screen fan we have one
of my favorite episodes so far
all about who would win in a cooking
showdown between gordon ramsay and bobby
flay what really blew my mind about this
episode was understanding what goes on
behind the scenes of cooking competition
shows
it is a surprise to say the least we
also have classic food debate episodes
like is a hot dog a sandwich and how to
optimize your fast food order to get the
most fries for your dollar
these episodes are just a lot of fun and
unlike ruining your favorite disney
movies a lot of the stuff you learn on
food theory can actually help you in
real life so you're still here listening
to me talk about it so click on over
watch a new episode today hit that
subscribe button
thank you for all of your support over
there it has meant the world to all of
us in what's been a miserable year so
all the theories you know and love are
still happening over here on film theory
but in the meantime i'll see you right
here
next week on film theory for something a
little bit different